[Music]
we're recording here we go my producers
called and I don't give a [ __ ] I told
him to go upstairs to get a sweater he
can have one but he didn't he said never
mind um
welcome to congratulations we're here
this is the sixth episode I believe and
thanks for everyone for listening I got
in a rhyme set I'm getting right to it
dude
I'm just getting right to it rude bless
um you know what I mean how am i [ __ ]
Jamaican Tings good dude I honestly
think that it's [ __ ] hilarious that
Drake sometimes talks like with a
Jamaican accent he is a Jamaican he's
just from Toronto right he's not a rude
boy is he is he a Jamaican ting I don't
think so do it but it's hilarious and he
just gets away with it he's like yeah
she's my sighting but he's not Jamaican
that would be long I thought it's all of
a sudden started talking lot is from now
reason people be like I bet Chris you
from New Jersey oh I know but you know
I'm not the body of a dying she she
mashed on me nobs - I'm a bird you're
[ __ ] you're not you're not Jamaican
why would he if I all of a sudden was
sort of walking around and been like
yeah if I was at a coffee shop and I was
like yeah I want to get an iced
americano and then what do you want my
my rude wants to get actually an iced
vanilla latte if you could hook that up
for that for his for him and then his
and then and then his ting his side ting
wants just a hot coffee thanks so let's
see let's recap this I'm one americano
for the rude wah he wants um a nice
America or a nice coffee or whatever it
is and then his sighting just wants a
hot coffee it's [ __ ] ridiculous
they'd look at me like I'm an [ __ ]
anyway what's up rude waz um I'm here I
uh I didn't I didn't again once again I
didn't really right
anything down is very stupid of me um
but this is the sixth episode dude and
we're doing it babies how are my babies
Kumbi hi pixel annoying actually
um alright dude let's talk about some
some good [ __ ] I was in where was I
Madison and Milwaukee I did two shows I
did one in Madison which was packed
great theater and then I did a Milwaukee
show and it was oke Milwaukee one was
great Madison was a little bit amateur
night I don't like when people come out
and call out [ __ ] like I'm a jukebox and
do like do the booth do the one bit or
they try to impress it with their
knowledge shut up laughs and be quiet
laughs and don't laugh um those are the
two options when you go to a comedy show
laughs and don't laugh don't scream out
things you got the Rhett syndrome
don't have Thrones syndrome we got
threat syndrome I guess sorry but um so
they did that was a little bit Amateur
Night and they did that and it it makes
me mad deep inside when that happens
because it said it's a disrespectful
it's a disrespectful for to me but more
importantly it's a sad disrespectful for
the people who paid monies to go enjoy a
show they don't like that so the
Milwaukee show was [ __ ] really fun
though man I was loosey-goosey having a
silly goose time and is good and then
well one guy got mad he was like dude um
you have the same he tweeted afterwards
he was like you had the same closer last
time I saw you for three years which
first of all is not true I have not had
the joke for three years second of all
that's how Comedy Works one time I was
watching Jerry Lewis talk about it do an
interview about comedy he said hey
that's comedy babe it was a [ __ ] but
also that is comedy babe
hey that's comedy babe my brother and I
still say to each other that's comedy
babe and we laughed so hard hey saqqaq
but um yeah dude that's how it works
plus he was like griping on the internet
that I did a [ __ ] four-minute bit
everything else he hadn't seen but yo
bro not cool
same joke three years in a row not true
first of all maybe at most two years but
also I only hit markets like once every
two years so this [ __ ]
traveling to see me what a weirdo
um anyway so it was good man I had a
good time in uh in milwaukee madison was
okay but um
Madison's really a nice place thumb and
it's like a cute [ __ ] town or city I
guess and it's got the Capitol building
I don't know by the way what the Capitol
building
I guess capital buildings all kind of
look the same I guess I just realized
that even though I'm 36 and we were
driving the driver that I had was
driving me around and I literally this
[ __ ] made me fiery red mad I got to work
on my anger a little bit because we're
driving and in the distance we see the
Capitol building
like that's how capitol buildings are
you're driving down the street and you
see the beautiful Capitol building at
the front like in the distance and
that's how it is supposed to be grand
and there of course we're driving down
the street with buildings on it and I
say to the driver
oh what's that building and he points to
the building on the right and he says I
don't know I think it's a bank or
something the bank I said yep I'm not
talking about the building we're driving
by I'm talking about the building up in
front the glorious [ __ ] dome-shaped
building he was like oh I think it's a
Chase Bank I was like disk and I got and
I just I looked at my opener and I was
just like and then my opener just looks
at me because the guys [ __ ] 75 and I
said yeah but I'm obviously not asking
what a Chase Bank is I got to work on
that though man I have to but I did the
shows and they were great I'm back in LA
now and I'm I'm in I'm in LA doing my
doing chillin with my rude boss um but
yeah I'm a [ __ ] on one right now I
got to calm down I'm sorry uh let's see
uh I got oh dude you know what I [ __ ]
saw recently Moneyball dude that movie
so good
if you don't like the movie Moneyball
you got no soul I think it's such a
[ __ ] good movie I watch it on the
plane and like it was so it was such a
good plane movie man it's a great movie
by the way period but like it I was like
it made me forget I was on the plane and
Brad Pitt's so good in it
Philip Seymour Hoffman is literally a
[ __ ] coach in it he's a baseball
manager I don't give a [ __ ] he's that's
how good he is and it's just so good man
and it's so interesting it's not that
like I guess it like that that's a movie
that the book was probably amazing and
then they could have really [ __ ] up
the movie because the movie was it's
like it's such a book like there's so
many intricate parts and it's all about
statistics and [ __ ] and how baseball
teams do well and but but they [ __ ]
nailed it man it was good and Jonah Hill
was [ __ ] really good he was nominated
for an Oscar um yeah it was so good it
was such a good movie by the last scene
I was like kind of tearing up actually a
really good man I think you'd like it if
you're a rude boy but um if you know you
have something to watch with your side
ting my buddy said that it's a really
good movie to watch it with watch with
your side ting because first of all no
he said he's seen it 18 times at least
with chicks because you can it you you
uh first of all it no girl has ever seen
it which is good because it's about
baseball right but it's still a romantic
movie a little bit in a way because it's
romantic about baseball and you and and
it's like it's good because you could
turn it off at any time also because
it's like not like there's no action in
it where you're like aw [ __ ] where
you're sitting on the edge of your seat
but you could just turn it off and then
in the middle just [ __ ] smash on your
side ting and and you're not really
missing anything and then just turn it
on later if you want after you know post
smash wrap up and just finish the movie
ting but um yeah so it's a great movie
dude you got to watch that movie I know
what came out in 2011 or whatever but
like I'm just like I don't really watch
the movies like that I sat next to this
guy on the plane though I always like to
sit on the window seat so I don't have
to get up if the guy has to go to the
bathroom like if the ting next to me has
to get if there's a rude boy next to me
and he needs to go to the bathroom I
don't have to get up if I don't want to
right so I always get the side I get the
you know the does the next to the window
right and there was a guy next to me
that was you know maybe in his 50s and I
thought when people talk too much it's
the most annoying thing but this guy
[ __ ] literally didn't say a word to
me he didn't say a word he didn't speak
he could have been mute I don't think he
was mute though they just didn't get it
I didn't have that mute vibe he just was
kind of a dude and I'd be like he was
sitting down already when I walked into
the thing and was like oh excuse me man
I gotta get by you and he just moved
he just got up in mood and I said oh
thanks man sorry about that said nothing
got up went to the bathroom I said hey
buddy you mind if I go to the bathroom
didn't say [ __ ] got up walked it walked
out I said thanks appreciate it didn't
say [ __ ] went to the bathroom came back
said hey bud he said nothing got up
walked in the aisle past him and said
sorry about that thanks a lot he said
nothing okay an hour and a half later I
had to go to the bathroom again there's
a five-hour flight I got up I said
excuse me bud you mind
he gets up said nothing walks out into
the aisle I said thanks sorry about that
he says nothing I go to the bathroom I
come back I said you mind if I get back
in he says nothing gets up and I walk in
and I don't say [ __ ] now I'm like all
right [ __ ] it no thanks then bud
you're not gonna acknowledge I I'm
speaking so then I sit down and I'm like
all right whatever who gives a [ __ ]
maybe he just doesn't care to talk fine
maybe in a bad mood then he goes to put
on his then the lady comes up the the
stewardess comes up and hands me his
blazer the guy's in a [ __ ]
button-down shirt
and slacks and nice shoes I'm in a
[ __ ] something that looks like you
know I have a wide [ __ ] neck t-shirt
with a pocket on it and pants that are
cuffed at the bottom and she hands me
the Blazer and I look at her and I was
like you think that [ __ ] Blazers mine
and she gives it oh woops and she gives
it to the guy he says nothing to her and
then he goes to put on the Blazer and
hits me in the [ __ ] face while he's
putting the Blazer on with his left arm
says nothing he doesn't apologize dude
literally the plane could have been
going down and he would have been like
just not saying [ __ ] like say something
sometimes if you are being if you are
being and not sleeping for five hours
and you don't say something even if
you're alone Wow Wow
dude when I'm alone for five hours
I've spoken no [ __ ] at least 32
times I'm talking to people that aren't
there I'm saying [ __ ] to myself I'm
talking to my dogs I'm laughing
sometimes I thought that was crazy but
dude if no it's not this guy was in
public on a [ __ ] plane didn't say
[ __ ] for five years hiya Krays oh that's
interesting
oh really did that you're crazy you
crazy person and he wasn't a mute don't
give me that [ __ ]
nobody tweeted me and be like maybe was
mute nope wasn't he was a [ __ ]
50-something year-old asian man that was
just a regular ass dude very weird very
weird hey man do me a favor don't punch
my face I not say something dude real
quick man I have it I have it I have a
favor if you ever punch me in the face
say something about it it's actually
unbelievable that was unbelievable talk
about a road block
so yeah yeah yeah
and even if by the way he was Asian if
you couldn't speak English I don't give
a [ __ ]
say at least look at me and be like a
hood you know he's Asian so if you're a
[ __ ] white guy you just if you don't
speak the language in Asia if I bump
into an Asian guy I go oh oh sorry but I
still speak my language or I learned the
word for sorry or whatever the [ __ ] you
know this guy [ __ ] punch me in the
face didn't even look at me and just
didn't even care to speak the [ __ ]
Asian language say something I don't
know what what race he was but say some
mumble moment Illinois do that I do that
hi do that um yeah I up by the way I got
it I got a [ __ ] alert here you don't
it um I was - I was actually talking
about this on my snapchat brought one
time I saw a girl on Instagram and she
was and she was waiting for her friend
and like drinking wine it said in the
description and she looked at the
Instagram and she goes like this she
looked at the picture or at the camera
and she goes she says like this she says
waiting game lost my [ __ ] lost my [ __ ]
that was her post waiting game no just
waiting it's not a game you're just
waiting Hey oh dude
worst game show ever hi welcome to
waiting game where we wait around for 30
seconds for our friends and go boo doo
doo ah you lost cuz we're all losers
wait waiting game and she sang it you're
just waiting if you eat a burger eaten
you're not playing the eating game dude
this [ __ ] [ __ ] killed me I'm at the
doctor's checkup game no hi bye dude oh
my god also if you're waiting for your
friend don't make me wait for your
friend too
don't [ __ ] put a video of you waiting
on the Internet I'm watching it now I'm
waiting worse content ever worse content
ever don't make me wait to when I'm not
waiting that's so rude rude game my
buddy used to tell me stories of girls
he would hang out with and it would end
in not having sex that's what the
equivalent of is that for the guy don't
tell me the [ __ ] story that you had
to [ __ ] do and not have sex
afterwards and now I got to listen to it
guess what I get to [ __ ] you now dude
that's what I get to do turn round dude
I get to [ __ ] you bro you told me that
boring story turn round if you tell me
that story about not having sex with a
girl turn round turn around put on that
song that goes closing time one last
call for alcohol turn round bro
imagine having sex and then that song
comes on on your iPad it doesn't matter
if it's a hooker immediately you fell in
love that's the most lovely song of all
time imagine you know cuz iPods you put
it on shuffle you're listening to Ice
Cube or some [ __ ] America's Most Wanted
and then you're [ __ ] a hooker and then
all of a sudden closing time one last
call for alcohol you go like this will
you marry me huh and you have an orgasm
doesn't matter if it's a hooker she goes
flat awkward game bro holy [ __ ]
remember that song it came out in like
1999 or whatever it was that's how 90s
it was it wasn't even a year it was just
1990 question mark close hey and every
bar played it at
closing time that's so annoying they
couldn't wait the employees till that
song came on closing time
I hate whiny ass bitch-ass voices like
that but that song rocks it does I don't
like any of the [ __ ] closing time so
whiny you sixteen maybe they were
sixteen Donovan no those guys probably
[ __ ] tour now and they have bigger
crowds than me no doubt and the whole
crowds just wait for that [ __ ]
closing time one last call for alcohol
you don't have to go home but don't stay
here I know what you wanna take me home
worst lyrics ever I have no [ __ ] idea
waiting game oh my god dude
um so yeah first ever fifth episode
sixth episode Semisonic Oh from 1998
dude album was called feeling strangely
fine as a defensive set defensive oking
defensive oh hello King defensive Oh
we'd like to have a word
ah I'm sorry I was listening to my
favorite album feeling strangely fine
and it's because everything is okay
trust me how do you [ __ ] make an
album called feeling strangely fine and
not be the most insecure person of all
time dude
hey feeling strangely fine how are you
how many of you talking to some of you
dude haven't seen in a while how's
everything going oh it's good man just
been feeling strangely fine you'd be
like oh by oh you would literally think
he got his dick sawn off and that's why
he's you know what I'm feeling sorry to
find why what why what's going on did
anybody say my dick was cut off or
something okay come on dude dick cut off
game
i'ma dude my producers crying laughing
because that's so [ __ ] C insecure
feeling strangely fine Semisonic even
semies even that's insecure just be
sonic well we don't want to go the whole
way I mean what there's probably people
more out there out there that are more
Sonic so let's just say Semisonic and
then they're even insecure you don't
have to go home but you can't stay here
do whatever you want ha it's up to you
don't take my advice my relationships
don't work but I'm feeling strangely
fine swear to God
oh my god dude God I got in this [ __ ]
podcast right now I mean come on
Wow the most ninety song of all time and
you remember the song I swear to God
even if you live in Zimbabwe to be like
yeah I remember
that's how night it was 1999 1990 a
question mark dude that song was the
song period wow it was so funny dude oh
man when that I would if you and if you
stayed till that song you're such a
white guy with flip-flops man God oh man
you know who even knew that song I'll
tell you what here's how [ __ ] dope
that song was that song came on if that
dude sitting next to me was listening to
that song he would [ __ ] he would have
sang along that's that's how [ __ ]
much he would be like closing a time
whoa notice color photo cola that's how
[ __ ] that's how dope it was I would
be like oh this guy speaks it is a semi
sonica oh man um for [ __ ] sake they
should play it old they should play at
old chela they should close the old
cello show old cello call it
Mel's they you can't just rip off
[ __ ] Coachella and then be like oh
well we're older than them old chela
that guy that suggested that didn't get
shot in the head that should be unfuckin
uh that show what on earth on the
Discovery Channel or whatever show that
is here we have a guy that didn't get
shot in the head even though he coined
the term old chela how has nobody killed
him
we've got satellite views of his
basement and hid and he's sitting he's
sitting in his house alive how did it
happen
let's go to a scientist well you know he
got he suggested old chela and we
thought maybe maybe after that he went
into hiding but he's not he's at his
house and he didn't get shot
we've got satellite pictures of it I
want them to do two old chela how could
you be like a really respected performer
I guess how could you be a really
respected performer and then be asked to
play old chela and be like yeah I get it
I know money I know I understand that
the [ __ ] answers money but like
that's what my uncle would say he'd be
like I'll give you a million reasons why
he would do it and even each reason was
a dollar in case you don't catch that
you know hey why did he play that part
in that movie that was an awful part now
I'll give you 250 thousand reasons dude
that's old-school to do that I'll give
you 250 thousand reasons I want to use
that phrase but for way little amount of
money dude uh why'd you do that show at
The Comedy Store I'll give you 15 I'll
give you 15 reasons I performed in the
original room on a Tuesday night I'll
give you 15 reasons oh my god if you
work minimum wage you should say that
God why do you work so hard at the
[ __ ] at Best Buy
I'll give you I'll give you eight eight
I'll give you eight reasons I'll give
you eight reasons an hour how long you
got do you have eight hours to sit
around I'll give you eight reasons each
of those hours I don't even know what
minimum wage is I'm such a [ __ ] loser
speaking of added touch because that's
out of touch to not know what minimum
wages I think it's like what is it like
it's ten okay it's ten fifty and I love
how the the liberals wanted it to be $15
and now they're just making robots
that's the best that's the best that's
so sad in reality but that's why it's
also you gotta laugh at it otherwise
you'll go kill yourself they're marching
they're out here marching needs to be
$15 needs to be $15 needs to be fifteen
dollars and people were like start the
production of robots immediately and now
you're going to roll by Wendy's and
they're going to be like would you like
ain't cheeseburger and you're like what
the [ __ ]
what would you like on would you like
fries with that hmm um oh no now people
are out of work
meet my [ __ ] robot dick mm you
complained too much now I work for free
here's your goddamn chicken fingers eat
my robot dick liberals Oh turn around
closing time one last call for alcohol
you don't have to go home but don't stay
here as he's [ __ ] you
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] everyone's so
backwards and all wrong
you know give him $15 give him $15 they
don't even have they don't even have
[ __ ] police men they literally don't
even have policemen like watching them
they just have robots watching them wait
[ __ ] [ __ ] this March all you want I'm
getting a job at Wendy's oh my god wait
a minute something is awry here comments
work at Burger King hello may I take
your move out of the way goddamn it to
the [ __ ] poor employee move out of
the way my turn oh my god oh my god
yeah but speaking about a touch dude you
ever see that [ __ ] a Garth Brooks
Facebook video I was talking about it
with Tom see
goroh apparently he talks about it on
his website a lot or I'm sorry on his
podcast a lot which I didn't know that
but [ __ ] [ __ ] man that I know you
know that Facebook thing he's like slick
stuff smooth stuff well I like that I'm
on Facebook now yeah it's 75 years too
late but you know what sometimes I wear
one shirt that looks like two shirts you
look at the right side and you're like
hey that's a black button-down but then
you look at the left side and it's
turquoise blue they shook did they sew
two shirts together well I like that
I'll take one how much is it three
thousand five hundred and seventy five
dollars I'll take two I like that it's
the most out of touch [ __ ] video of
all time my friend told me you know what
Facebook you could talk to people well I
really like that hey man are you getting
sucked off while you're shooting this
video why is it so goddamn creepy also
have you ever seen the top of Garth
Brooks [ __ ] head or was he or does he
is the top of his head literally a
cowboy hat what's on the top of his head
that he's hiding a [ __ ]
do you touch the top of his head when he
goes to bed when he takes his cowboy hat
off and does he say well I really like
that slick stuff raw stuff touch my
[ __ ] on the top of my head I like that
that's why I cover it up dude it's so
out of touch
hey man Facebook's been around since
1940 you don't need the [ __ ] peg so
let the conversation begin hey man the
conversations been going on since the
Year 1816 just because you're on
Facebook doesn't mean Facebook started
hey guess what I bought yesterday a car
I get in that car
look at first I didn't know about this
car thing but then my friend told me
about these beautiful little pods that
you just get in they got four wheels and
another wheel in front you and you could
just steer around well I like that and
then when the gas gets low because
that's what it runs on you just stop by
a place it's called the gas station and
you just reload the gas and you can just
drive wherever you want well I really
like that so let the driving begin hey
they invented a car in the year
six dude I feel like Garth Brooks is so
goddamn out of touch that you'd be like
hey Garth how much is a carton of milk
and he would say seventy-five dollars I
think we did that bit on [ __ ] 10 min
10 minute podcast the [ __ ] something
like that
i don't remember where i think i played
garth brooks or something and then i
don't remember mm-hmm
no i played me I was being me and I was
pretending that I didn't like I was I
made so much money or some [ __ ] and then
will sasso said while you really ought
to touch how much is a carton of milk
and I think I said 750 or some [ __ ] I
don't remember no like that really like
Diane so [ __ ] creepy um man I love I
love it but he has like legit fent he
has legit fans that he is legit fans so
for [ __ ] sake man he did start the
conversation for a lot of people I'm
sure people join Facebook because they
heard that this [ __ ] I've made a
facebook video garlis on Facebook I'm
getting on there he's on Facebook's I'm
getting on there
God gave me warning hi
Maggie get my shirt with the two that
the two shirts get my shirt that's black
on one side teal on the other and get my
hat
got to cover my [ __ ] Tom's on Facebook
well I'll be let's get this conversation
started get my goddamn keyboard sind
what up garth has his work dude
country's so big in Canada and that's
[ __ ] hilarious
the more north you get the bigger it
gets the more north you get the bigger
it gets that's so funny
the more south you get the bigger it
gets in America and then people are like
okay well [ __ ] this country stuff and
then the more north you get the bigger
it gets what's up with [ __ ]
extremities that they need country dude
oh my dogs gone and they buy it for one
I do not know iTunes oh it's good oh for
[ __ ] sake man really really really
really really really good so he's got
legit fans you know you have fans if you
do something and if you have talent you
have fans if you work hard and you gain
a fanbase you don't have fans if you
just have people that like your pictures
on Instagram or a favor of your tweets
therefore if you've got a few thousand
people following you on social media and
you refer to them as fans by a boat by
some bags by some sand by some rope take
the boat out into the ocean fill the
bags with sand tie one end of the rope
onto the bags and tie the other end of
the rope onto each one of your ankles
and jump overboard dude you don't have
fans
if you don't do [ __ ] okay you don't have
you don't do [ __ ] and that goes all the
way up to Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian
doesn't have fans
she has likers she has followers and I
don't know if she says hey thanks for
all my fans whatever no you can't be a
fan of fun somebody if they don't do
[ __ ] you're only a fan of somebody if
they have talent and they [ __ ]
implement it in some way in their life
you can't even be you you can't be a fan
of somebody that shits around you loser
if you like that what does that say
about you some guy named Craig doesn't
have fans
he just has friends and not friends
that's what you got if you got do
something and I don't mean by the way
models have fans because they [ __ ]
work hard they do their [ __ ] poses
they know what the [ __ ] up but not you
don't have fans if you just take some
[ __ ] pictures near a bike you don't
well would you take one of those
pictures where you're where you're where
you're running in sand and you're
holding a hand behind you and whoever's
holding that your hand is taking the
picture and the only person per part of
the other picture you can see of the
person is their hand holding your hand
you don't have fans wish I could go back
comment if you're a fan by you know it
is for you closing time get a job god
damn it I get it bro but no you don't
have fans
you got you got people that are watching
you you got creeps you chick you got
guys that want to [ __ ] you you got guys
and dubai that comment under your it
love your sexy tits [ __ ] it you know and
if you're a dude well I've talked about
this already and it's only episode six
I'm repeating if you're a [ __ ] dude
model your I learned that the most well
paid
male model makes 1.5 million dollars a
year that's the most well paid male
model the richest male model makes one
point five dollars a year that's [ __ ]
so that's really sad actually
I mean look making a million point five
a year is amazing but that's the top of
the profession that means that there's
so many dudes out there working out so
hard and eating kale and a cardboard
[ __ ] card for breakfast and they make
in like three thousand dollars a year
that's [ __ ] up dude if you're a male
model you're a chair that's what you are
the girl sits on you and then the girl
girl makes [ __ ] 25k for the day and
they go like this to you thanks and then
you go to craft service and they're like
no no that's for her then she doesn't
even need it because she's like I I
can't trying to keep I don't want to be
fat oh my god
I don't to be [ __ ] fat yeah don't
call your [ __ ] people that are
looking at your fans if you don't do
[ __ ]
um but you know what do I know
all right well I don't know what the
[ __ ] else to talk about do it
I [ __ ] really went hard for like 35
minutes and now I'm just like oh I got
you know what I could do I could look at
the [ __ ] hashtags is what I can do I
can I can look at the hashtag of
congratulations pod that's how I led to
I not by the way do that that's how I
get get questioned I take two questions
from you just tweet me congratulations
pod and and you can do that alright
let's see here let's hear what I got oh
yeah that's
right this is what I wanted to talk
about this guy writes by the way rate
and review will be really awesome um we
have like a lot of actually a lot of
ratings which is really cool especially
for a one that just started out um but
this reviews at the top and it's from
February 7th I don't know how they do
this by the way cuz the reviews are all
over the place like it's like February
7th and then here's one from the 21st
and then here's one got a lot of good
ratings which is great thank you so much
for doing that and and you can leave
comments this dude reviews my [ __ ]
podcast and this is what the heading of
it is I'm gay now and then he writes
literally as soon as I turn on the
podcast sorry literally as soon as I
turn the podcast on I became gay I press
the play button and then immediately I
sucked three dicks to completion in
parenthesis I never thought that would
happen to me I've always felt that being
gay was wrong but my but I'm balls deep
in a Haitian while I typed this well
this guy is definitely a homophobic and
maybe racist so that's cool but he gave
me five stars so thanks I don't know why
this happened the podcast is great and
Chris is great I'm not saying you're
going to be gay if you listen to it or
anything just in case anybody was
worried out out there I'm just saying
that's what happened to me Wow well uh
you know hey he gave me five stars so
appreciate that that was tweeted to me
by somebody tweeted me that Cory Berkman
Cory Berkman sounds like a fake name
would you a character in a movie
Cory Berkman sounds like the [ __ ] guy
who owns the opposite company that comes
in and tries to bury your company in the
movie like Anna Vince found Vaughan
movie that didn't make much money
hi oh great here comes Cory Berkman and
his phones like mild deal with it and
then just [ __ ] it up worse that's what
your name is um
creeper kmen man that's a bitch-ass name
I mean I'm sure you're a nice guy
uh-uh if
question is that I think it was just ask
questions to ask questions worst first
date experience you've had or heard of
someone happened dude I actually had it
I went on a date once it was the first
date with the girl you'll know why
obviously this was the first one um and
she was this Russian girl um and she we
were having dinner
oh god this was so long ago and she told
me that because she had a kid and the
kid was like three and she was like just
casually if it was like was like you
know because when it was Russian you
know because of in them after I after I
had my son I had two very bad depression
in one and I was so bad I wanted to kill
him Oh dinner's over
hey don't say that on the first date or
any date she told me she wanted to
[ __ ] she heard the person was so bad
that she was nervous she had she wanted
to kill her son oh hey what's crazier
that or telling somebody that on their
first date I went oh oh I like was like
oh you wanted to go you'd wanted to kill
your son and she said yeah it was really
bad I divorced Russian accent ever but
you know what I mean real bad real bad
mom real bad mom hey real bad mom I
don't mean to harp on the postpartum
depression I know it's a real thing I
get it but Jesus Christ man uh this is a
comedy podcast so if you're thinking
about complaining about what I just said
[ __ ] you yeah
what's the worst
you ever had to sleep on the road when
you were coming up as a comedian this is
from Peter um I don't know and you know
not really I just hotels that's it what
did you expect a trench one time I slept
in a trench um
and I put leaves over it because it was
raining it was in Vietnam I was doing a
show in Vietnam uh but yeah this is
interesting thoughts on murder podcasts
I actually this is from hll snowy laelia
change your name and um you get to pick
your Twitter handle change it's Noel
Elia change it your Star Wars character
no change it snow loyal Elia um I just
started listening to a murder podcast
GARP murder garage or some [ __ ] marek
some murder garage or some I don't know
what the [ __ ] actually here let me look
it up it was about a murder my opener
told me to listen to it which meet
immediately makes me want to not like it
because you know when you have friends
that suggest you [ __ ] you're like [ __ ]
you I'm not going to like it because
you're shitty and you don't have good
taste you know you do that if you don't
hate your friends you ain't [ __ ] let me
tell you for real true crime garage is
what it's called
true crime garage and it it was pretty
good I just listened to one about some
yogurt murders yogurt shop murders in
Austin uh it's kind of [ __ ] I don't
know Austin yogurt murder Oh yogurt shop
murders is what it's called then I
googled it a little bit there wasn't
much on it how are there not movies
about all this [ __ ] why do they make
these shitty crime movies and then they
don't take these movies and make them
real movies they made a movie about the
West Memphis Three this how dumb I am
I watched the documentaries on the West
Memphis Three about how these kids were
sixteen and just because the cops wanted
him to go to jail because they said they
worship the devil or some [ __ ] or they
were into like rock music that they put
him in jail and they thought they'd
they killed these other kids and they
didn't do it they didn't do it and they
put him in jail for a long time and then
they got out even though there's still
like convicted murderers they let them
out because they couldn't overturn it or
some [ __ ] but they let him out i watch
the three documentaries about them and
then just turned on a movie up with
Colin Firth and Reese Witherspoon and I
was watching this [ __ ] movie about
this crime and then at the end I
realized oh this was the movie based on
those documentaries I had no idea that's
how dumb I was and the movie took place
in West Memphis and at the end it was
like this never they never found this
that night I was like oh this shit's the
[ __ ] West Memphis Three Colin Firth
playing a book Colin Firth playing a
southern guy is amazing by the way he's
a he's amazing he's a great actor and
you did a great job but look at Colin
Firth - look at Colin Firth and not be
like oh he's British is like just not
gonna happen
that's like looking at Denzel Washington
being like he's a white guy he's so the
most British looking guy it just was
hard for me to buy it but he was so good
he really is so good he's so good in the
[ __ ] stuttering movie stuttering King
what the [ __ ] that called King speech
where he's just like lie lie lie lie lie
lie where he's like trying to [ __ ]
speak lie lie lie lie lie lie it's so
good cuz it's like it kind of looks like
he's bad acting but he like flipped it
on its ass where you're like dude maybe
that's really what it is like lilah III
I'm the king
lilah I'm speaking I I lie that I it was
so good dude he was so good it's just
all close up of him [ __ ] trying to
speak a lie the light I I lie and it's
so uncomfortable he's good he deserved
the Oscar but he's British lie lie lie
lie lie lie lie lie lie
that's how British he is him when he
stutters he's not on Loy Loy
what's going on or I can't walk right
no that's Australian I guess a cranky
i T i-10 krumpers um yeah but the movie
Devil's knot is what it's called and it
was uh it was okay it was okay it was it
was okay they're good actors Manresa
Witherspoon's [ __ ] good
and uh Colin Firth is good and the other
guy in there was good too who's really
good and I don't I I actually met him
like [ __ ] [ __ ] man it must be over 20
years ago now in Hollywood and he hadn't
been working and now he works all the
time
um and I haven't talked to him in a long
long time but he's a great [ __ ] actor
uh Devils not I'll look him up right
here I can't remember his name that's
how long it's been I hung out with him
maybe three or four times uh
he's huge he's like six five and [ __ ]
ripped of course he's not showing up on
IMDB hmm I want I got to tell you who he
is though cuz I'm giving him a shout-out
[ __ ] is he Bruce Greenwood good too it's
not him Jesus he's not how far down any
is it is it he's on that other movie
Legion with Bettany Paul Bettany oh by
the way Paul Bettany is much British guy
ever look at him
imagine plant try and play a New York
cop he could probably do it but liège
and he's unleashing I'll just look not
the [ __ ] tea new TV show the movie uh
oh here is kevin durand that's his name
great actor oh yeah he played [ __ ] I
think he played a sabertooth in the
Wolverine movie he's in the strain of
courses in Vikings the guy's [ __ ] six
five and looks like a Viking
yeah Devil's not John Mark Byers he
played was a guy
probably secretly killed those kids um I
like that actor uh he's in real steel
Robin Hood of course that Logan movie
looks [ __ ] awesome what is it about
Hugh Jackman that's so dope
I'm I know he's handsome and I know he's
[ __ ] vain doubt I love Hugh Jackman
awesome I want to see that movie so cool
to be in a blazer and also have those
[ __ ] claws you know no guy would not
see that movie and then they just call
it Logan like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you we'll
call it Logan we don't want to call it
Wolverine if you don't know [ __ ] you if
you don't know what this is yeah and
then the Billboard is just him his eyes
closed up and his claws and he's just
teary-eyed which is like I Drive by down
Sunset I see that I want to pull over
and I'd be like we're all a little bit
Logan looks awesome it looks awesome I
can't wait to see it better than
Moneyball probably not but you know
Moneyball was amazing Philip Seymour
Hoffman is so good how does he play a
baseball manager that's such a [ __ ] and
then also play the guy from Big Lebowski
the butler
that's so he's so good dude [ __ ] he died
man that's such that's so [ __ ] man I
did a table read once with him and I
showed up and it was him Jason
gordon-levitt Joseph Gordon almost Jones
Edward Joe almost Joseph Gordon and uma
Thurman uh Joe Montaigne uh by the way
how about Joe Montana about the fact
that in the world
there's Joe Montana and also Joe Montana
go [ __ ] yourself
Chris D'Elia and Chris deal D'Elia
Chris D'Elia Chris D'Elia and Chris
D'Elia dude if there was a [ __ ]
successful quarterback the most famous
quarterback of all time Chris D'Elia
I jump off a bridge Joe Montaigne kills
it though so it was oma Thurman Joe
Montaigne Philip Seymour Hoffman Joseph
gordon-levitt
John Joseph Jones Borden and so
disrespectful and another famous girl
that her name escapes me but she's like
really good I think she played Allison
Wonder Alice in Alice in Wonderland or
some [ __ ] and like two or three other
famous people and and [ __ ] me dude
like I don't even know I felt like such
a little [ __ ] in there and they had
everyone had like Oh leaves Liev
Schreiber was there who was just
he's like the real-life Darth Vader when
he walks in a room he like oh [ __ ] oh
okay
all right everybody be cool no I'm Liev
Schreiber and he just [ __ ] is awesome
he's like the the most alpha dude and he
just sits and reads the lines and he
just is like this [ __ ] and he's so good
I want to fight him that's how good he
is I want to fight him and lose just so
he can have another win that's how much
I like him uh so yeah um so so I did the
table read and it was a mini-series
thing I'm not trying to tell what it's
about whatever but uh cuz I don't know
when it's coming out or whatever the
light of day and I know for sure I'm not
going to be in it but everyone else will
be and I'll be like oh that's that movie
even Philip Seymour Hoffman will be in
it he'll come back from the dead and do
it and they won't give me a part for
sure no doubt and although not not not
to be of course that would I mean that
would make me the most if [ __ ] Philip
Seymour Hoffman did a movie post death
of course that would be of course
everyone will go see that
so yes put him in the movie but anyway
it's a backtrack give Moe but what I'm
saying is that's yeah that's it was a
miniseries the [ __ ] table read
a nine hours long and I had all the
little [ __ ] parts where I was like
excuse me and that's my line but and I
played 47 different people I played like
cop 1 and cop 2 and then looker-on or
maid they even gave me the women parts
to just because like they were like Liv
Schreiber was like I want to see him
play all the [ __ ] [ __ ] parts um but
uh yeah so he played saber-tooth too by
the way
he also played Sabretooth um remember
the other guy didn't play same person I
think about I don't know there were two
different severities
oh no there was a saber-toothed movie I
think wasn't there I don't [ __ ] know
anyway did that and and it was cool to
be in a room with all that filled the
room was so small and I was in a room
with so many stars um yeah and the table
read was for a [ __ ] huge director
which I don't want to say because but
but he yeah it was awesome I guess he
saw me do stand-up and wanted me to come
to it and it wasn't a comedy so I was
like so confused um but I don't know uh
[ __ ] it's been 53 minutes dude pretty
awesome um I guess I'm [ __ ] running
out of steam here dude I don't know how
these guys talk for three hours but uh
let's see if there's some more good
questions and if not I'll wrap it up um
[Music]
somebody just asked me what do you think
of Tom Segura I'm in a pod I love Tom I
was hanging out with him in Vancouver
the other day we had dinner
shout out to Tom Segura very funny
comedian who would we
fight Tom Cruise or Leo DiCaprio from
Patrick aschbrenner that's a cool name
however is handle this paddy man 69
change it um I feel like I feel like I
don't know that's a good question well
it's a terrible question but it's
terrible to even think about that but um
I think that maybe Tom Cruise because
Tom Cruise would uh probably um hey play
has more anger you know what I mean Tom
Cruise probably he's been famous for a
long time so he probably feels like
people don't like him for the real him
well no [ __ ] you know DiCaprio was
famous when he was way longer actually a
kid but Tom Cruise is older Leo would
win Leo would win I feel like he's got
to have I don't know though Tom Cruise
looks like he's got that [ __ ] dark
secret you know like he's got like I
don't know maybe Tom Cruise I don't know
you stumped me bro hey you stumped me
paddy man 69 change it so that's that's
it dude that's all I got for today
that I don't have good there's not good
questions I'm saying but let's go over
my tour dates dude Chris D'Elia calm
check it out I'm a lot of I'm a lot of
uh I have a lot of uh dates coming up
and I my new special comes out in on on
in on Netflix in like May or June we
don't have a date yet but before that
I'm touring it still before I got a
start right new [ __ ] and I am going to
be in Virginia Beach Virginia Beach
Raleigh North Carolina Greensboro North
Carolina Oxnard California Melbourne
Australia Sydney Australia Tempe Arizona
Phoenix as well West Palm Beach Florida
Baltimore Atlantic City Huntington New
York and that is Long Island or yes I
think that's so that's all I think
that's sold out that one actually but
maybe not check it out
so those are the dates and more also
chris d'elia comm follow me on instagram
Chris D'Elia
um and follow me on Twitter crystally if
you have questions hit hashtag
congratulations pod right
congratulations pod and my snapchat is
Chris D'Elia so until next time uh I'll
you'll be able to listen to me again in
a week oh subscribe and rate the thing
that really helps if you subscribe and
tell your friends about this podcast
because bro if this [ __ ] doesn't keep
climbing I'm out dude so until next time
waiting game and row right now it's
closing time see you guys later thanks
for listening
[Music]